Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
I want to talk today about Boko Haram which
was formed in Nigeria in 2002, but I want
to begin in the year 1100-ish.
So Hank, we have this idea that Islam spread
primarily through conquest, but in fact, in
many places, including Sub-Saharan Africa,
Islam spread primarily by trade.
So back in the year 1100-ish, leaders in what
is now Northern Nigeria started to convert
to Islam.
They were trading with North African Berbers
and by the 18th century, most of the people
in what is now Northern Nigeria and also what
is now Southwestern Nigeria were Muslims.
But those Sub-Saharan African empires never
spread to the rest of Southern Nigeria so
those people were not Muslims.
Instead, in the 19th century, when a bunch
of European missionaries showed up, many of
those people in the rest of Southern Nigeria
became Christians.
What is now Nigeria was colonized by the British
for much of the 20th century, but Northern
Nigeria was controlled by what's known as
indirect rule.
Like the local emirs were allowed to run everything
as long as they pledged allegiance to the
British and also, paid them a portion of their
money.
Now, as far as colonization goes, that seems
like a pretty good deal, but also meant there
was much less western-style education in Northern
Nigeria than in Southern Nigeria which was
much more directly ruled by the British.
So the south ended up with most of the doctors
and the lawyers and the bureaucrats.
Also, all of the oil is in the south.
I should pause here to say that this is of
course over simplifying.
There are hundreds of languages spoken in
Nigeria and hundreds of different ethnic groups.
There are many Christians living in predominantly
Muslim communities; many Muslims living in
predominantly Christian communities.
So it's definitely not as simple as a divide
between North and South, but there is a big
gap there.
Ok Hank, so one of the many catastrophes of
colonization is that it created borders that
were convenient to Europeans, but not necessarily
to the people who, like, lived in the actual
places.
So in 1960, Nigeria gains independence which
is awesome except it's never actually been,
like, a unified political entity.
Hank, there's this famous moment in James
Joyce's novel, "Ulysses" where Leopold Bloom
is asked what a nation is, and Bloom answers,
"A nation is the same people living in the
same place - or also living in different places."
But 1960, Nigeria was more like different
people living in the same place which led
to a bunch of coups and then, eventually,
to a 1967 civil war.
Parts of Southern Nigeria seceded and became
the Republic of Biafra.
And the rest of Nigeria was like, "Wait, no.
We should be one Nigeria.
Also, all the oil is in your new country."
There was a huge civil war for two and a half
years.
More than a million people died, but in the
end, Nigeria won, and the Republic of Biafra
ceased to exist, and the country was reunited.
So Nigeria today is a really interesting country.
It's split almost evenly between Christians
and Muslims.
It has one of the fastest growing economies
in the world and very little national debt.
It's the largest economy in Africa and the
20th largest in the world.
Their film industry generates 10 billion dollars
in sales a year.
But it's also the last nation in Africa that
still has polio, which is found only in the
north, and life expectancy in Nigeria is 52.
That's lower than it is in Somalia which doesn't
even have a government.
In much of Northern Nigeria, fewer than half
of kids even go to elementary school.
Female literacy is over 50% and while the
country's overall economy grows over 8% a
year, in the north, absolute poverty is actually
increasing.
Hank, it's easy enough to say that religion
is the problem here, right?
Except there are a lot of Muslims living in
the southwest of Nigeria where female literacy
is over 90% and the economy is growing really
well.
The problem is partly resource allegation.
Like, Nigeria's export economy is just a smidge
dependent upon petroleum which is found almost
exclusively in the south.
But there's also all these legacies of colonialism
and indirect rule which means less effective
federal governance in everything from education
to the armed forces.
So this was the Northern Nigeria that saw
Boko Haram emerge in 2002, a region disproportionately
impoverished, uneducated, and poorly governed.
The words Boko Haram literally mean "western
education is forbidden".
The group was founded by a guy named Mohammed
Yusuf who himself had a western-style education
and spoke English.
Although he believed that the earth is flat
and that rain is not caused by evaporation,
so maybe it wasn't such a great education.
In 2002, he began recruiting unemployed young
people into his movement, railing against
official corruption, which is rampant, and
also advocating for the creation of Islamic
state.
But Boko Haram didn't actually become a military
organization until Yusuf was arrested and
then shortly thereafter, executed in 2009.
Over a thousand people were killed in the
riots that followed Mohammed Yusuf's execution,
and after that, Boko Haram became increasingly
militant and crazy.
I mean, this is an organization that claims
they want to restore like righteousness and
justice to Nigeria, but they fund themselves
like primarily through drug trafficking and
bank robbery.
In 2011, Boko Haram was behind Nigeria's first
ever suicide bombing.
On Christmas of that year, they killed 41
people via bombings and shootings in churches.
In 2012, they killed at least 792 people.
And in 2013, they murdered nine women who
were distributing polio vaccines.
Polio vaccines!
They also murdered 54 mostly Muslim college
students while they were sleeping in their
dorms.
And then, in 2014, Boko Haram got worldwide
attention when they kidnapped 276 girls from
inside of classrooms.
The attacks since then have only gotten worse.
On January 3rd of this year, they seized the
town of Baga, burned it to the ground, murdered
as many as 2000 people.
And now, Boko Haram controls the northeastern
corner of Nigeria where they've instituted
a version of sharia law so extreme that not
only has the likes of it never been seen in
Sub-Saharan Africa, but it's, like, too extreme
for al-Qaeda.
They regularly massacre people who won't fight
for them, and they've begun attacks in Niger
and Chad and Cameroon.
Boko Haram still has an army between 7,000-10,000
people, and it's difficult to understand what
those people are thinking, at least what the
leaders are thinking.
I mean, they conscript a lot of people; they
have a lot of child soldiers; they force preteen
girls to be suicide bombers.
And it's hard to understand that evil.
Then again, I don't know if I need to understand
it, but I do need to know about it.
I mean, not knowing about this stuff is really
problematic, Hank, because one of the great
tragedies of Boko Haram is that they have
been allowed to grow for the last ten years
because the Nigerian government and the world
community haven't done a good enough job of
noticing how terrible they are.
So I think it's really important to learn
about Boko Haram and not let their atrocities
go unnoticed, but I also think it's important
to understand that literally 99.9% of Nigerians
do not support Boko Haram.
And Hank, it's also important to remember
that just a few days ago, two Muslim volunteers
in a northern town sacrificed their lives
to keep a Boko Haram suicide bomber from entering
a city market where she would have killed
hundreds of people.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.